Here's the result code and what we want to do is replace the list tocrawl and crawled with sets.
This make more sense--what we really want these things to be is an ordered collections
without duplicates, which is exactly what a set is.
The first thing we need to do is change the initialization.
Instead of starting out with the listed, we need to start it out with the set containing that one only.
For crawled, we want to start with an empty set.
The good news is we don't actually have to change much of the rest of this code.
Here we're using page not in crawled that in operation behaves similarly for sets as it did for list.
So we can use that just as we were. We don't need to change anything.
What we want to do is change the part where we used the union and we're going to change this
to use the set update passing in out links and updating the value of tocrawl
to be union of tocrawl in outlinks.
We need to make one other change, which is here. We use append which is define for list.
The reason it's not called append for sets is because it doesn't add to the end of a set.
The set has new order, so it makes more sense to call this add,
which is the name of the set up operation that adds an element to the set.
So these are all the changes that we need to make.
The other change that we can make is now we can delete the union code,
which we no longer need because sets are already defined to provide union..